Russell he'll fire one and that's good
that's a three by D'Angelo Russell
Jefferson bring it up it's one of those
empty possessions we talked about I
talked about ending is one of the keys
grabbed from outside three berries one
cows cos love bird fire from the top
industry I was a good screen that time
by Quincy Acy the free levert up and
they handed back deliver six seconds
five levert to AC fires the jumper
scores on that one only for three and he
finds heiress who dumps it out to he see
at the baseline flatlines once levert a
fake and a drive along the baseline get
down to AC make the passes and the reads
levert whips one out to the corner
upstairs errors fire that's good down oh
well that one nearly threw it away again
back to Russell's firing and scoring the
Angelo Russell wanted no part of
shooting it
in Twitty anymore and my quit mainly
that was a rainbow there left it wide
open dared him to shoot that look worked
for three that's good at a time ago red
hyper or clogged from the Kings outside
dr crab behind his back Allen left alone
in the corner nothing but net for the
big fella has been cut to seven
for three that's good
Mama's gotta get up pogo stick his way
through the two defenders eros rises up
scores again for either team Paris crab
fake shot good see we just have with a
whole scrambling trying to stop turbo
penetration one of those dogs at night
man we got do some talking to the people
in the higher ups crap China he is right
on the money as how it popped out
I don't grab again got again and all of
this is that all of this is a single
double screen TV the hollis-jefferson
[Music]
move to the corner crab shooting and
scoring it boy holiday is it over or CH
Jefferson
long shot to that sport in Brussels
they're just flowing into their hot fan
doors and the perfect weekend
advantage there's AC and he rattles one
down Casey oh my goodness man of the
people I go up and see my people you
need to get up there see to be they want
to see me oh [ __ ] there's AC out of the
car oh goodness
sighs I think Toronto's that helped his
team in the Eastern Conference and then
in the Western Conference Houston
Houston did what he will bring it up
Aris up quick oh wow my agency can you
know what though but should look at the
assist
Oh to assist there's 220 another three
extra 33 assists on a watch here
from 30 either 35 36 percent